[Music]
i work in dynamical systems
what a dynamical system is is a space
with a bunch of rules that on it that
tell you what happens to each point in
that space
what i want to do is then be able to
predict long-term behavior
about what happens to the system as you
keep applying that rule
over and over this kind of space the
ones i look at are very abstract but you
could think of them as something
like planets rotating around the sun and
you take a snapshot where each one is
once a second
and then try to tell me where they will
be millions of years into the future
one of the tools i use in my research is
symbolic dynamics
and what this is is a mechanism to take
a complicated
abstract dynamical system and recode it
in a simpler way so that we can study it
let's say you're standing and observing
a traffic light and i'm going to pretend
there's no yellow to make it simpler
it just alternates between red and green
and let's say it changes every 30
seconds
and every 30 seconds i might down the
color of the traffic light
using a 0 to say that it's red and a 1
to say that it's green and my pattern
will just say zero
one zero one zero one it'll continue
like that forever more
in other words this is a super simple
pattern because it's just
this little block of zero and one
repeated all the time it's a periodic
pattern
now let's say i look at that same
traffic light but i don't measure it
every 30 seconds
maybe i measure it every 31 seconds or
every 32 seconds
and when i do this i might see the same
number in a row twice
so this is something that i can detect
using symbolic dynamics
it's really a beautiful part of math to
find
connections which are not apparent and
finding structures
where you didn't know that they were
going to be there to me this is one of
the
best parts about doing research
you